15. kwietnia
rada unii europejskiej przyjęła dyrektywę budynkową
która wymuszać będzie na obywatelach unii
kosztowne remonty klimatyczne
zakazane zostaną piece na gaz i węgiel
właściciele domów będą zmuszeni do wymiany okien
drzwi i ocieplenia budynku
polaków kosztować to będzie półtora biliona złotych
tak naprawdę jest to dyrektywa wywłaszczeniowa
uderzająca najmocniej w ludzi najbiedniejszych
których nie będzie stać na wymianę źródła ogrzewania
a najgorsze jest to
że nasz rząd wstrzymał się OD głosu
dając milczącą zgodę na przepisy
które uderzą w kieszenie milionów polaków
konfederacja zatrzyma ekologiczne szaleństwo unii
europejskiej
nie pozwolimy ograbić naszych rodaków w imię zielonej
ideologii brukseli
chcemy żyć normalnie konfederacja